Richard minitor how many times and when
has Osama bin-laden declared war on the
US numerous times Peter I see at least
five times publicly since 1996 I mean
that's kind of one of the extraordinary
things that that appears in my book
which I was kind of surprised that the
other media mainstream media in new york
times what have you hadn't really picked
up on especially back in the 90s it's
not every day that a terrorist declares
war on the united states bin Laden been
doing it since February 1996 openly
calling press conferences and issuing
communique and in both Arabic any
english-language newspapers desperately
trying to get our attention and what was
the response beginning in 1996
well our response yeah President
Clinton's response wasn't particularly
strong he seemed distracted by the by
the 1996 election as early as February
he when the first declaration of war
came out he basically said said and did
nothing the CIA had set up a special
station to monitor bin Laden in January
1996 at the counterterrorism center
which is on the seventh floor the main
building of the CIA and this was about
all that he did was was allow the
analysts to be in one place and talk to
each other while our enemies plotted and
calculated well let's go back to the
World Trade Center bombing in 1993 you
talk about that in your book also and
you quote Bill Clinton as saying that
people should not overreact to the World
Trade Center bombing that's right that
was that was President Clinton's
reaction he he only spoke publicly to
the Nation about the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing which were ever happened
one his first really thirty days in
office was sworn in on January 20th the
bottom the bombing happened less than a
month later in February he only spoke
publicly wants and it was a radio
address a Saturday morning radio address
in which part of it was devoted to the
World Trade Center bombing the bulk of
it was devoted to the president's
economic plan which had yet to be
introduced to the Congress at that point
I think it was subsequently defeated but
he never visited the World Trade Center
site a couple of days after the bombing
he was in New Jersey basically three
miles away a 15-minute limousine a ride
away and his senior aides were debating
whether or not the president should tube
it should visit the World Trade Center
site and he refused to go he wanted to
give a speech on job training instead
which he did give and when asked about
the the World Trade Center attack by
reporters he urged Americans and as you
said not to overreact to go about your
normal lives you know please a you know
ignore this this first major a terrorist
attack on American soil I just wonder
what how Clinton would have acted
differently it's one of those great
questions that you know historians can
debate but we can never really know the
answer what would have happened if
President Clinton actually went and
visited the site of the bombing and he
saw that yawning mouth of a crater 60
feet wide a hundred feet deep and saw
the you know the families of the victims
would he have would he have recognized
that binlong was a serious threat just
just don't know numbers are on the
screen we're talking with Richard minute
to her new book losing bin Laden how
Bill Clinton's failures unleashed global
terror this is the cover of the book
mister minitor what was the US
government's reaction did did was there
a direct connection to Osama bin Laden
at that time that they're aware of and
was there movement behind the scenes to
capture him or to get him let me back up
a little bit the first bin Laden's first
attack on Americans and I document this
in my book losing bin Laden but you know
it's not widely known was actually
December 1992 was as after President
Clinton won the election before he'd
been it sworn in to office so the CIA
had begun in in December to a mass of a
good stockpile of information on bin
Laden from sources in Middle East and
elsewhere so in February 1993 about two
and a half months later when the World
Trade Center was hit the CIA had a good
supply of information but it was never
never it never did the investigators get
a chance to look at that because Clinton
made a decision very early on and turn
it over to the FBI not a bad idea
they're excellent investigatory force
to specifically make it a criminal
investigation now that that might not
mean much to the average American the
FBI does colonel investigations all the
time but that comes with a special
restriction Peter that means that they
cannot share anything that they learn
outside the four walls of the New York
office of the FBI
so CIA director Jim Woolsey told me how
frustrated he was that the largest
terrorist attack on American soil to
that date
had occurred and any 24 year old special
agent of the FBI knew more about that
attack and about the terrorists plotting
against America than he did as CIA
director it was just two extraordinary
decision by Clinton and it was the
beginning of a pattern it was why we
missed so many opportunities in the
nineteen nineties because he saw it as a
law enforcement matter and not as a war
even though our enemies including bin
Laden himself had openly and repeatedly
declared war on us when was the first
time that the US had a reasonable chance
to catch bin Laden and what was heard
what happened well I would different
people have different definitions of
reasonable I think one was heartbreaking
early opportunities occurred on March
3rd 1996 and on that date a Sudanese
general named Fatih or WA had flown in
to Washington from his home city of
Khartoum Sudan specifically to meet
senior career State Department people
and the CIA and the idea was to combat
terrorism in his country and forge a
better relationship with us and in that
first meeting which I document was a
secret meeting but I talked to everyone
in the room
the CIA handed him a list here's what
you got to do to fix it here's how you
could make things better and number two
on that list was take care of a Solomon
Laden you know he's in your country he's
in Sudan he's been there for years and
we know that that's an active terrorist
hub three days later at another secret
meeting this just with the CIA and
frontier or himself they offered to
arrest bin Laden and turn him over to us
and that was simply extraordinary there
have been some debate of whether or not
that offer actually occurred I've seen
documents on the offer I've seen
internal
documents inside the government debating
the merits of that offer I've talked to
government officials inside the US as
well some Clinton defenders say that I'm
basing this solely on the word of a
Sudanese general I did interview that
Sudanese general I don't think anyone
else has except for the Village Voice
but I did and I also talked to the
Americans I talked to people on both
sides as a reporter and it's ample
evidence this offer occurred and was
repeated actually several times in the
next few months
it's what the Clinton administration
decided to do with that offer that's
extraordinary what they decided to do
was essentially nothing for several
months and then to say hey why don't you
kick him out of your country the reason
why they turned down the offer and this
sandy Berger who was then deputy
national security adviser and Steve
Simon who was a member the gnash
Security Council both him on the record
is saying look they just wanted to kick
the issue of in Laden past the 96
election this was the spring of 96
they're afraid of doing any kind of deal
with Sudan because Sudan was listed as a
state sponsor of terrorism and it was
for all intents and purposes a spat IRS
spy satellites identified 22 satellite
22 a camps there some of which were
training bin Laden so they certainly
weren't terrorists sponsor and you don't
want to be seen as doing deals with
terrorists but in this case it would
have made sense to do that deal because
probably with 9/11 wouldn't have
happened first call-up for Richard
minitor is from Los Angeles good morning
good morning good morning mr. minister
that's some pretty shameful behavior
that you're detailing here I guess my
question is is more about is more about
you and the writing of this book do you
find I've seen the way Democrats and the
Clinton people have reacted in the past
to such heavy criticism normally it's
with attacks and smears and I've won I'm
wondering whether you've found yourself
being the focus of anything like that at
this point oh sure I've been attacked a
few times but boy you're up early in Los
Angeles god bless you sure I was sandy
Berger I called me up screaming and
yelling about a year into my two-year
investigation that that's that I put
into this book saying he'd heard about
the he'd I'd interviewed him several
times and he'd also heard about the fact
that I've interviewed Savelle all the
people and called me up about this time
on a Sunday morning about a year
go and screaming and yelling on the
phone saying I'm gonna destroy you in
Washington and you know you're basically
accusing me of killing 3,000 people and
just swearing like a sailor and so it
was it was hard to hear but on the other
hand I mean as a ink-stained wretch I
mean we're not like these famous
television people it's nice to be
noticed sometimes who was director of
the CIA in 96 96 that was guy named John
Deutsch and what was his relationship
with Bill Clinton John Deutsch was
appointed by Clinton he was you know I
mean professionally I mean did they did
they work closely together the hello I
assume they did have a better working
relationship than that between Woolsey
and the and the President and that's
because the president taken a lot of
heat on Capitol Hill I mean what
happened in you know let's put this in
context November 1994 for the first time
in 40 years Republicans take control of
both houses of Congress so suddenly what
the president regarded those those pesky
voices on talk radio suddenly those
voices became a lot more important they
just elected a majority to the other to
the legislative branch and the
Republican criticism saying hey you got
to start talking to your CIA director
this is a matter of national security
he knew that he had to forge a better
relationship with George but also
Deutsch was not an innovator like
Woolsey Deutsch wasn't trying to reform
the agency he wasn't trying to hire more
Arabic language translators he wasn't
trying to force the analysts to test
their theories against each other to see
who proved out to be correct
he wasn't as aggressive so Clinton of
course didn't see him as threatening he
was able to the president was able to
maintain his posture of doing the same
to you know basically doing nothing was
there anyone in the Clinton
administration
for pushing to capture bin Laden or to
take up this offer from the Sudanese
well those are two separate questions
really Peter because there were a number
of people in the Clinton ministration
and I'd I don't want to leave anyone
with the impression that in my book
losing bin Laden is just an endless
attack on the president and his men
because there are a lot of decent
hard-working guys at the CIA the FBI
especially at the street level
who performed some heroic deeds and
actually saved some lives and also
inside the Clinton White House Richard
Clarke who's essentially the
counterterrorism czar was was dogged in
his pursuit of first Ramsey use of the
World Trade Center bombing mastermind
and later bin Laden Michael Sheehan at
the US State Department he was there
State to bother their counterterrorism
coordinator you know also very
aggressive off many trips to the Middle
East again pushing this we've got to get
these guys so you know it's there
you know the good and bad in every
administration and there certainly were
a number of hard-working dedicated
people who had the right idea in the
Clinton White House the tragedy is they
just weren't listening to next call for
Richard miniature Bowie Maryland I guess
the author is presenting a very balanced
case at least in Dominion and I want to
ask him this in the 90s Republicans got
credit for the Congress got credit for
welfare reform balanced budgets and many
other things and people basically say
the president got dragged along he
really wasn't a leader Republican
revolution did that fine and much of is
true my question to you this day impeach
the president and on on the Monica
Lewinsky and Paula Jones case they
investigated him on the China case and
whitewater and go through the list
now it's they're gonna get credit for
welfare reform and balanced budgets I
don't see how a person trying to be fair
could not blame them because they
clearly set the agenda for the second
half of the Clinton administration at
least be 60 to 70 percent of the blame
I'm talking about the Republican
Congress for not impeaching him or in
bin Laden or investigating on bin Laden
if you're going to give them credit for
welfare reform bounds budget tax cuts
etc and I'm not saying this author is in
with the crowd I really don't know his
background but the point is he's being
used by the conservative crowd to say
see this guy says and he documents and I
believe every fact in your book
and but I'm just saying the way you put
it in perspective I'm not you the media
puts it in perspective I'm saying you're
gonna give the Republicans credit for
the second half of the Clinton
administration's accomplishments you
know tax cuts balanced budget surplus
you know and
clearly said the agenda by impeaching
him when the public was against it so
they had the the intestinal fortitude to
go against public will and said the
agenda they have to be responsible it
should be how Bill Clinton and the
Republicans in Congress lost bin Laden
and you talk quite a bit also about
politics in your book a bit yeah I don't
deal with impeachment I don't take a
position in the book on impeachment I
refer to some of the other Clinton
scandals the Clinton campaign
fundraising scandals especially but
really only in passing I think a care
for will leader in five maybe three or
four paragraphs in this book well I'm
going yet out of eighty four thousand
words I don't deal with the scandal or
try to stay focused on what he did and
what he knew about bin Laden and when he
knew it but you have a chapter called
the friend of Bill that's right about a
Pakistani gentleman named monster II
guess absolutely who was he and why do
you put him in this book I put him in
this book well first of all Mansour is
just a very interesting story
he and there's the 1996 campaign
unrolled Clinton realized that he needed
especially with Republicans in control
of Congress and Republicans were very
confident that year they thought that
they were gonna capture the White House
as well that he needed to raise a lot of
money for television ads and he kind of
snuck up on the Republicans because he
ran the ads all across the country
except for New York Washington Los
Angeles and so among other sources he
raised money from was a guy named
monster HS and it's in my book chapter
the friend of Bill but unlike most of
the Friends of Bill cuz to raise that
money for that campaign he had to had to
could make a lot of new friends fast and
raise a lot of soft money and he raised
hundreds of thousands of dollars from
entourages who's a pakistani-american
a Wall Street businessman but a monster
was a bit of a patriot he he didn't want
to use his access to the president for
personal aggrandizement what he really
wanted to do was help fight extremism
Muslim extremism in his native Pakistan
or in his father's native Pakistan and
so he hoped he uses access to the
President to get funding for secular
schools in in Pakistan and then later he
went he journeyed to the Sudan
and Ave this is after just after bin
Laden and left because he thought that
Sudan was the key to these Islamic
extremism in Pakistan and he met with
the leaders of that country the
president of the country that the
radical Hassan Al Farabi who was the
speaker that assembly a Legislative
Assembly in that country and he got a
series of offers which he brought back
to his friends in the Clinton White
House John Podesta the chief of staff
sometimes meeting with the President
himself
and of course meeting with national
security visor sandy Berger and he
passed on all these offers saying you
know for more than five years bin Laden
was in Sudan they've gathered a lot of
intelligence on him they want to share
it with us they want a better
relationship with us why don't you guys
take a look at it and so that's that's
the story the story of an American
citizen monstera just trying to do the
right thing trying to connect the
intelligence files on bin Laden in Sudan
where they had detailed dossiers on all
of bin Laden's key players surveillance
photographs they had they knew a lot
about his financial transactions because
they'd actually tapped his a fax machine
and they wanted to pass all this on to
us and the puttin Administration said
sorry no thanks and that that's why his
stories in the book next call from
Richard Minotaur Indianapolis good
morning good morning and thanks for
taking my call you know I remember the
attack on the USS Cole and that was in
the summer of 2000 and I generally I
agree with President Bush but I want
your guests to explain why what
President Bush did specifically during
January 2002 August 2001 that really
demonstrated a willingness to deal
forcefully with bin Laden and I want him
to explain why President Bush had the
press conferences with the salad eprint
to assure us that they were are allied
now Baker emboss law firm that's James
Baker's law firm he represents the Saudi
government and baker-bots is
representing the Saudi prime minister
against the 9/11 families a former
attorney for Baker mombasa is now the
ambassador for Saudi Arabia and he was
appointed by President Bush and that
gentleman used to be President Bush's
person
lawyer I'm afraid I can't think of his
name I think the Saudi government is
just so tied into our political system
on both sides I really don't think is
Democrat or Republican I think they go
wherever they need to go to maintain
that influence and so I think I think
there were a lot of people on both sides
of the aisle who ignored a lot of things
because it was financially expedient for
them thank you well a couple of things
we call heard a lot of different
thoughts in there one is yeah it's it's
absolutely the case that the Saudis and
their lobbies have been very good at
hiring key former officials from both
Democratic and Republican
administrations you know you could
probably run a cabinet meeting just
gathering together all their lobbyists
these days and you know one thing that
I've always found disturb me I don't
really talk about in my book with my
books about Clinton and bin Laden not
specifically about the Saudis one thing
I've always found disturbing is the
number of u.s. ambassadors to Saudi
Arabia who end up as lobbyists for Saudi
Arabia and you know it would be an
interesting reform to say that if you're
going to be an ambassador to a country
you can't go on the payroll as a
lobbyist for that country for a minimum
of five years or ten years it should be
a waiting period so that well people are
acting as ambassador they're not looking
over the horizon for possible gain by
lobbying for that country in the future
now I'm not impugning any particular
ambassadors I'm just making a general
statement about good government here
Clinton administration response to the
USS Cole bombing oh right October 2000
the USS Cole steams into Aden Harbor in
Yemen for refueling this was a pretty
routine thing US Navy ships have been
refueling there about once a month for
for the past two years and at the time
the US Navy was not told about key
intelligence which I report for the
first time in my book that's starting in
July of mm probably the summer that the
the caller was thinking about starting
in July of 2000 al-qaeda started to plot
to destroy US naval vessels and the
White House received intelligence
through Richard Clarke that a group in
Lebanon affiliate with al Qaeda was
planning to attack a naval vessel while
tragedy struck
over 2000 the coal was hauled by an
explosion and was sinking 17 sailors
were dead another 44 were injured and
the question is what do we do about it
so cut back to the White House in the
wood-paneled Situation Room in the in
the basement of the White House key
Clinton advisors met to decide on what
what course of action to recommend to
President Clinton now to some people it
certainly looked like an act of war we
went into a neutral or friendly harbor
the coal was menacing to no one and
suddenly it was attacked and certainly
some of our wars have started when the
US newest Navy ships had been attacked
in harbors such as a Spanish American
warrant Richard Clark the
counterterrorism coordinator went to the
off-the-shelf plans drawn up by the
Defense Department for which showed all
of the targets and coordinates for
hitting bin Laden's camps in Afghanistan
as well as some some Taliban assets and
he put those three-ring binders on the
table and said hey let's blow him up and
then that's a quote let's blow them up
but around the table every the Clinton
cabinet people hold held a very
different view for mr. Clark Secretary
of State Madeleine Albright said well if
we bomb the Afghanistan now it's not a
good time to bomb Muslims it'll it'll
essentially blow up the Middle East
peace process and doom any chances
President Clinton has of winning the
Nobel Prize for peace by setting up a
case of Perpetual peace between the
Palestinians and Israelis at least that
was the hope Attorney General Janet Reno
wanted a full investigation which
everyone in the room knew would take
months CIA director George Tenet now he
personally thought that bin Laden was
behind it but he too wanted a long
investigation or a thorough
investigation most surprisingly his
Secretary of Defense William Cohen now
this ship had been attacked you know
I've been essentially working for him as
Secretary of Defense and yet he did not
want a military response either he did
not want to to respond after 17 American
sailors have been killed murdered really
instead he said and according to several
sources I talked to in the room that
attacking u.s. warship was quote not
sufficient provocation close quote and
and that that's really surprising and
shocking to me now I understand he sends
back
away from that a little bit but no one
he certainly hasn't denied that he was
not in favor of retaliatory strike
against against Afghanistan or against
bin Laden's suit camps their Taliban
infrastructure there he certainly wasn't
in favor of that in fact no one was
except for Clarke and that's why the
President President Clinton did nothing
Newport Newport News Virginia here on
the air obviously I do appreciate c-span
I have a question for the armed for the
author and I would like to press this
the question by saying that been lying
as we all know was a problem way before
the Clinton years no one is tad more
into the Middle East business dealings
and the Bush administration and the
Conservatives that go along with them in
this thing's like it's the flavor of the
month to exonerate the president
administration and the history that they
had on the Reagan and the first Bush
that created these problems so my
question is this I haven't read the book
and I do plan to read it but why is it
that we're dealing with Clinton when
he's only a little speck and the whole
problem that created bin lion al Qaeda
and the current situation that exists in
the Middle East does your book address
the history of this situation starting
with the Bush family and their hideous
and crony as' dealings with the Saudis
and everyone else in the Middle East
well the reason why I'd ended up writing
a book about Clinton and bin Laden is
first of all I didn't think anyone had
done it I thought this was a real gap in
our understanding about a very important
issue and so I wanted to fill that gap I
did a two-year investigation I talked to
dozens of high-level Clinton
ministration sources career federal
employees CIA State Department Defense
Department FBI and so on so to really
try to get a complete picture of what
was going on and really where I started
my investigation was with September 11th
September 11th didn't just happen it was
planned for years and the intelligence
sources that I talked to said that the
planning for 9/11 started in May of 1998
in the calden camp in Afghanistan May of
1998 so the planning was been going on
for years and during a lot of those
years of that planning were the Clinton
years
so I became then very interested in
Clinton and bin Laden
what did Clinton know about bin Laden
and when did he know it and what did he
do about it
and I think those are interesting
questions now my next book is going to
deal with with Bush and whatnot and it's
gonna pick up where this leaves off in
January 2001 and we're gonna look at
what Bush did before 9/11 and after but
I don't want to make any conclusions on
the air now because of my investigation
has just started but this book is a
result of two years work and you know
hope you take a look at it Toronto good
morning good morning I'd like to tell
you folks down there that the Canadians
are still your good allies sometimes it
doesn't look that way but the grass
roots au pair still supports what
America is doing against terrorism I'd
like to ask the author in my opinion I
always had a good opinion of President
Clinton however I never had a good
opinion of who he had surrounding him I
looked at people like Reno and Albright
and and the defense minister I don't
think these people were giving him the
right advice he might not have taken it
too well but second question is when we
look at your country we can't understand
after after September 11th why hasn't
anybody you know got fired over this the
two people that I would look at I would
look at that Senator Shelby from down
south he was on that investing he was on
that Intelligence Committee and then you
had the other guy Graham was on the
Intelligence Committee and both of these
guys are running for president now so we
can't understand you know if that would
have happened up here or England
certainly people would have got the ax
by now but you know how come nobody's
been a help point you know feet held to
the fire on this deal well a couple of
things first of all I want to say that
Canada has been a great supporter of the
United States in its war on terrorism
and with Canada's cooperation President
Clinton was able to break up some of the
Millennium plots which could have killed
thousands of innocent Americans on on
the Millennium of 19 1999 so that that's
kind of an untold story which the media
ignored as well but that aside to get
directly to the question of
first of all I don't think that the
Republican from Alabama senator Shelby
is running for president maybe I'm
misinformed but I don't think he is Bob
Graham is running a quixotic campaign
for president be surprised if he gets it
but certainly both of these men Shelby
and Graham were instrumental in in
pushing Bill Clinton to do more so why
they should step down I'm a little
mystified why but when they were on the
Intelligence Committee they were quite
active they they increased the amount of
funds that Clinton had for
counterterrorism and for other things
and Shelby and himself and I've
interviewed him several times was very
aggressive in encouraging the Kalina
stration to do more now another thing to
remember is the United States is not
like Canada in the sense that it's not a
parliamentary democracy and in
parliamentary democracies like Britain
and Canada you see a lot more
resignations it's a lot these are those
are coalition governments or fragile
governments you can have an election any
time and so there's a lot more pressure
to fire people in our system where there
are fixed times for elections you see
lot less resignations proportionately
it's just a long term feature of the
system it's not a conspiracy to keep the
incompetent in charge there have been
some people at the lower levels have
quit or encouraged to retire here so
there has been some accountability but
your system and the British system tends
to force a greater number of
resignations than ours does and that
goes back over a hundred years Syracuse
New York good morning you're on with
Richard minitor yeah how you doing guys
all right hello go ahead okay yeah to me
of course this book is a lot of Monday
morning quarterbacking that's that's the
way a lot of these type of research
books happen after the fact you know
what what should we have done
differently it's a classic Monday
morning quarterbacking and of course the
topic it's an attack on Clinton which of
course the rush scumball crowd is gonna
love this book but my take on this is
who even knew about bin Laden before
9/11 in the general public like myself
hardly even heard of the guy he was some
Bedouin pipsqueak you talk about he had
a war against us
what country does he belong to where is
his Navy where is his army richard
minitor oh well some interesting points
in there from the caller you know you
know look whenever you look back into
history you're essentially doing what
the caller calls Monday morning
quarterbacking you know it's a I don't
have the ability to look forward into
the future I could probably write a more
interesting book if I could but I can
but you know looking back into what went
wrong and what went right and learning
from those two things that's why we
study history
that's why especially in enduring war on
terror you want to look at the first
phase in a war on terror you know the
bush did not invent the war on terror
Clinton did Bush is fighting it perhaps
more successfully certainly more
dramatically in Phase two of the war on
terror but phase one was Bill Clinton
and and we need to know what he did and
what and and what he who didn't do and
what lessons we can learn from that
that's just vital to to understanding
how our world works so I wouldn't want
to ignore the past I want to learn from
it now
as for who knew about bin Laden you know
until I really became serious in this
two-year investigation for my book
losing bin Laden that was a view I held
that he wasn't widely known but as I
started to look through government
documents you know the State Department
prominently mentioned him in reports on
terrorism going back to 1995
Time magazine did articles and on him in
1996-97 Reader's Digest the largest
circulation english-language magazine in
the world and in an American magazine
had a cover story on him in 1998 you
know what the headline of that cover
story was this man wants you dead next
call comes from Paris France good
morning
okay yeah I agree completely but I've
already two questions require yes or no
the CIA meeting with mr. bin Laden and
Dubai in the US military hospital in
July and that was in the figure in the
figure oh yes federal Paris and we all
the whole Internet community is frames
for an answer of that is the true is
that not true and also September 10 the
meeting Pakistani general much or
something head of the intelligence
Pakistani intelligence and Senator
Graham is that true one day before 9/11
thank you that's what I want that you
know Thank You caller Richard respond of
those two things in reverse order I
don't know about the Graham meeting so I
can't comment on it one way or the other
but I can't be more helpful on the other
issue I saw the report in the Figaro and
let's just say the standards of French
journalism are not the same as the
standards of journalism as is practiced
here in America those tend to be
discursive essay type pieces and they're
not fact checked as much by editors and
some of it turns out to be more
interesting than true I did talk to a
member of French intelligence who's
responsible for the Middle East about
whether or not there had been any
contacts between any Western
intelligence agencies and bin Laden
personally anywhere in the world and as
far as French intelligence was aware or
at least the good fellow I talked to in
French intelligence
there had been no contact between any
Western intelligence agencies the Brits
the Americans the French the Germans and
bin Laden ever ever so it just doesn't
look like it happened Silver Spring
Maryland good morning good morning sir I
hope your book will be selected for the
talking book program I'm blind and read
my books on on tape through the National
Library Service for the blind and
physically handicapped well I'd be happy
to read my book on audio tape you know
for the Talking Book service if if that
ever you know anyone ever asked me about
that I'd be pleased to do it okay I've
heard Rush Limbaugh
talk about been long before so I'm sure
he's going to say that you are the part
of the echo effect that he talks about
on this show and your book is a huge see
I told you so that's what we're rush
would say I have a question at another
angle here in 1992 when Bill Clinton was
running for president he mentioned many
times that Hillary was going to be his
cohort and we were going to get two for
the price of one I like to know what
Hillary
had any role in this because she was a
huge influence in that administration
well no one doubts that Hillary Clinton
was a huge influence in the clinton
ministration especially the first
Clinton administration especially the
early years she exerted an enormous
influence for a first lady there is an
interesting scene which I document in my
book in chapter 3 which is I deal with
the connection between bin Laden and the
events which we could loosely call Black
Hawk Down the battle in Somalia October
3rd and 4th 1993 in which the night
before the assault that to arrest Aidid
that had led to the firefight that we
now call Black Hawk Down the night
before that George Stephanopoulos
received a late-night call from the
White House and it was clear that both
Hillary and Bill were on the line and
they wanted to cancel us an appearance
that the president is going to make the
next day at a Catholic Church here in
the nation's capital now a traditional
about once a year to bless the opening
of the Supreme Court the president goes
and and to attend the this Catholic
Church service with the nine members of
the US Supreme Court I guess on that day
no one's worried about separation of
church and state it's a long tradition
that goes back many years has never
never really caused a problem but for
the first time in history
Clinton was thinking about not going and
the reason why was think about not going
is because Hillary didn't want him to go
she was afraid they're gonna be pro-life
protesters and as I detailed in my book
I don't remember the jokes just now but
she she was telling anti pro-life jokes
and Stephanopoulos had to convince the
president to to go otherwise he might
you know alienate the Catholic vote and
they thought what everything in terms of
the demographics of elections inside the
Clinton White House especially in the
early years there just thought election
election election and she attended the
service Hillary attended the service
with Bill and as Americans are dying in
Mogadishu she's taking notes from the
sermon about how she can you know to try
to twist the sermon around to that house
she could market her health care plan
and in there they get into the limo and
it's clear that now a number of
Americans upwards of 40 at that point
have been killed in
ooh Somalia and she's and she's she's
cracking jokes about about the pro-life
movement so it just shows a disconnect
between you know the partisan politics
on one side and matters of life and
death and national security on the other
Sun Valley California good morning
yes I'm appalled as I sit here listening
to you apparently completely oblivious
to the fact that during the Reagan
administration we brought mr. bin Laden
into this country along with his forces
and trains them and then funded them and
armed them and you're gonna sit here and
write a book about how Clinton's
responsible for the whole bin Laden
thing in 9/11 you're not bringing up the
fact that George W Bush repealed a whole
bunch of anti-terrorism measures before
9/11 then mr. Clinton had put in I mean
you know if you're gonna talk about been
losing bin Laden why don't you write
another book of creating bin Laden and
let's get down to the facts about how
all this started well it's very
important when you cite facts that they
actually are facts I looked into the
connection between the funding for the
Afghan rebels in the 1980s was much of
which was supplied by the CIA and bin
Laden and one of the questions I asked
and I answered in Chapter one of my book
losing bin Laden is did the CIA fund
them and how do we know what they did
and I talked to the two men who were one
after the other who were the CIA station
Chiefs responsible for dispersing the
money to the Afghan rebels in the 1980s
bill Park me and Milt Bearden these are
the names of the two station chiefs and
I told them that I know I rely wanted to
know what happened I wanted to know what
they could say on the record I looked at
other sources as well and talked to many
other people and they categorically
denied that any CIA funds or any US
funds had gone to any Arabs let alone to
bin Laden the bin Laden was not a major
player in Afghanistan he was never
brought to the United States for
training in fact very very few of the
Afghan rebels were brought in for
training the Afghan rebels that were
brought here were brought here to be
treated in
America's hospitals the training that
was conducted was conducted in Pakistan
not here there's no link between the
Reagan administration or US intelligence
and bin Laden there's not a document
there's not a canceled check there's
just nothing there and I looked into
this about as thoroughly as one can I
talked to the guys on the ground who
responsible for passing out the close to
1 billion dollars a year and I was
looking for it because if I could have
established that link it would have been
a very nice headline it would have been
great for my book it's just not true sir
it's just not true adelante you're on
with Richard minitor yes I got a couple
questions for you
the tourist belly bill that affected the
CIA I wonder if you found any
involvement that really did hurt the
pursuit of bin Laden with that and also
when I was in Mexico in April 1995 I
heard some broadcast on the American
radio stations down there that they
immediately went for Arab terrorists
that they were the ones that caused the
attack on the Oklahoma City Building
that's my question
well I think the Oklahoma City bombing
investigation was was voluminous and
thorough there are some sort of
tantalizing clues there were some Arab
extremist connections between them and
the Michigan militia the the Americans
who carried out the bombing in 1995 I've
never seen that proven definitively I
haven't looked into it and maybe it was
perhaps as much detail as a caller has
but it's it's I don't deal with it in my
book I deal with the things that we know
for certain that bin Laden was behind
not not the things that we suspect if
there are a number of things we suspect
that he he or his organization were
behind that's certainly one of the
things that some people suspect he was
but I haven't seen any compelling
evidence to demonstrate that he was
actually behind the Oklahoma City
bombing in Appendix A of your book the
Iraq al Qaeda connection
hmm did you find a connection I thought
well I found a lot of evidence pointing
to a connection in intelligence it's not
like science or medicine there's not
absolute proof but you look at it's
suggestive patterns you look at links
and I saw a lot
one of those I deal with in the appendix
is the fact that there are documented
meetings between Iraqi intelligence
mostly the external intelligence was
what they call their Mahabharat meeting
with al-qaeda as early as 1993 in
Khartoum Sudan and this was observed by
Sudanese intelligence they took serve
dishes the photographs they recorded the
names of the agents and so on and I saw
some of those records so we see a
pattern of meetings certainly between
Iraqi intelligence and al-qaeda going
back to 93 again picking up great
intensity in 95 96 97 we see visits to
Baghdad by senior bin Laden operatives
in January in February I believe of 97
we know this is documented and on the
public record that some male Qaeda
forces trained at a facility south of
Baghdad called Salman pakka
what makes this facility interesting is
it has a Boeing 707 permanently based
there so that you can practice
hijackings and a number of terrorist
organizations Hamas Hezbollah and of
course al-qaeda used that to practice
hijack use a great way to Train
generalists a terrorist to hijack a
plane is to have an actual plane to
practice on and they have one south of
Baghdad and there's a lot of other
connections there and you know it's
probably too complicated to go into but
I urge the the curious to take a look
Richard Minotaur is the author of this
book losing bin Laden he is also a
senior fellow at the Center for new
Europe what is that that is a think tank
based in Brussels Belgium that studies
public policy both American public
policy and mostly a European public
policy we support free trade a peace
tolerance deregulation privatization a
freer economy for for Europe and America
and you live in both Brussels and
Washington yeah shuttle back and forth
where do you feel safer interestingly I
would I feel safer in Washington now
you're probably thinking that's a big
target but one of the problems that we
have not yet dealt with in since in the
post 9/11 world is how Europeans have
not gotten serious but cracking al-qaeda
cells the two assassins of Massoud who
was the head of the North Alliance and
until 9/11 so September 9th actually two
days before 9/11 those two assassins
were Arabs caring Belgian passports and
Brussels is in Belgium they found a
large al-qaeda cell there and didn't
weren't that aggressive and breaking it
up or getting arrests where you know and
I think the mainstream media has kind of
ignored this but the the
counterterrorism in America has been
extremely active of an FBI source I
talked to fairly regularly says that on
average the FBI breaks up one cell a day
in the United States one cell a day
that's a lot
last call for Richard minitor Modesto
California good morning good morning
sometimes I wonder if some of our major
news networks realize the damage their
economic news is doing to our economy
for example many people being
interviewed on national TV makes such
negative statements like I'm so afraid
I'm going to lose my job then I'm
drastically cutting back my spending
then many people watching will say to
themselves
I'm afraid also maybe I should cut back
my spending too and I would like to
suggest that when people hear this
negative interviewing they write the
news networks telling them if they can't
find people less negative to interview
you're going to turn off their economic
segments when it comes on
and it seems as though many reporters
interview the most native people they
can possibly find and thank you sure
well news is when the plane crash is not
when it takes off on time and
non-scheduled you know so you know it's
a business where we seek out egative ISM
for better or for worse but I think most
thoughtful people who watch economic
coverage of the news you know discount
for what they hear on TV they know that
there's always a tendency to go towards
the negative and I think they try and
discount that a bit anyway Richard
minitor is the author of this book
losing bin Laden thanks for being with
us